august is upon us which means the summer
is starting to wind down but that
doesn't mean that the game releases are
slowing down here is a list of the
biggest games releasing in august 2022
16 years after the series debut and nine
years after the last numbered entry
saints row is back instead of joining a
gang that has already been established
you'll be making a name for yourself and
building up what will become the
legendary saints however don't think of
this as a prequel to the original game
saints row features a brand new cast of
characters and a new setting santo aliso
a huge and vibrant sandbox in the
american southwest like previous games
in the series saints row's gameplay loop
revolves around seizing territory from
rival gangs like los panteros or martial
defense industries gunplay and traversal
are what you've come to expect from the
series however you'll have a few more
options when it comes to vehicle combat
sainsrow is shooting its way onto ps4
ps5 xbox one series x and s and pc via
the epic game store on august 23rd
in cult of the lamb you play as a
possessed lamb who has been saved from
an untimely death by an ominous stranger
all you have to do in return is build a
loyal following in their name in order
to do this you must explore the randomly
generated world and destroy the
non-believers and false prophets you'll
perform dark rituals give sermons
collect resources to build structures
with and train your loyal flock of
woodland creatures i swear if the art
style were different and it wasn't cute
little animal characters this game would
be so much darker you too can join the
call when this game releases on ps5 xbox
series x and s switch and pc on august
11th
football is back and once again has
managed to improve on last year's game
perhaps the biggest new feature in
madden nfl 23 is the field sense feature
that ea promises will deliver more
control at all positions in every mode
ea said that this new system will help
deliver ultra realistic gameplay
including new animations and player
control mechanics madden nfl 23 also
updates face of the franchise with a new
experience called the league there will
be new position specific mechanics and
player focused cameras franchise mode
meanwhile will offer simplified team
building mechanics in terms of visuals
madden nfl 23 aims to offer a new level
of visual realism in all stages of the
football experience there will be new
player locked 4k touchdown cameras that
aim to match with the latest nfl tv
broadcast offer you can continue to
secretly pretend you're tom brady when
madden nfl 23 drops on august 19th for
pc and every console except switch
do you think rocket league is cool but
you consider yourself more of a golfer
well turbo golf racing is perfect for
you in turbo golf racing courses are a
mix of golf links and race tracks and it
looks like getting your ball into the
green and into the hole will be a matter
of speed and positioning as much as
finesse and aim a key difference from
rocket league is that turbo golf racing
puts more emphasis on the race to get
the ball where it belongs rather than
the full contact wallops of squaring off
against another team hit the links in an
all-new way when turbo golf racing comes
to xbox one series x and s and pc on
august 4. so you remember two point
hospital and all the lives that you
ruined by not hiring enough staff to
help patients well what if i told you
you could ruin the lives of confused
young adults instead sounds fun right in
two point campus you can build the
university of your dreams and pack it
with crazy courses and the best staff
that money can buy for some college is
considered the best years of their lives
so it's up to you to make sure that
these students work hard and play harder
or the other way around if that's how
you get down two point canvas is
registering for classes on august 9th
for every console and pc
rumbleverse may have missed its initial
february release date but now it's ready
to put your free time in a headlock
rumbleverse is a 40 player free to play
battle royale where you'll take on the
role of custom made pro wrestlers
fighting across grapple city the city
name alone is enough to make me want to
give this game a shot during a match you
can find weapons like bats and folding
chairs as well as climb skyscrapers
across the city and perform high impact
moves like suplexes and power bombs from
the top of the building onto the streets
below get ready to slam your way to
victory when rumbleverse comes to pc and
every console except switch on august
11. the game's first season will begin a
week later on august 18th
first released on ps4 in 2018 and
remastered for ps5 in 2020 marvel
spider-man is now swinging onto pcs for
2022 in the game you play as spider-man
of course fighting crime and keeping the
streets of new york safe from iconic
spidey villains but you'll also get to
take off the suit and experience peter's
struggles to balance his personal life
and career while the fate of the city
rests on his shoulders i hope you're
ready to fall in love with mary jane
because marvel spider-man is headed to
pc on august 12th
roller drum is what you get when you
take skating tricks high scores and a
bunch of guns and mix them all together
in a pod coming from the developer of
aliali world roller drum trades
skateboards for roller skates and side
scrolling courses for 3d arenas the big
twist is that you're not alone in these
arenas they're filled with enemies
called house players whose goal is to
murder you roller drum is a blood sport
in which your objective in each level is
to kill all the house players before
they can kill you and to look awesome
doing it clearing enemies can also help
you maximize your score because as you
take out the opposition you gain
multipliers that increase the points you
earn from landing tricks you can skate
and shoot your way to victory when
roller drum releases for ps4 ps5 and pc
on august 16th
developed by mostly a one-man team and
published by humble games midnight fight
express is an isometric 3d brawler that
features non-stop over-the-top action in
the game you play as a former member of
the criminal underworld that is lured
back into your violent ways by a
mysterious drone however there's a good
reason you have until sunset to stop a
city-wide criminal takeover to do this
you'll take on waves of enemies across
41 handcrafted levels using your fists
along with knives guns toilet plungers
and more you can see if you have what it
takes to save the city when midnight
fight express drops on august 23rd for
ps4 xbox one switch and pc
behind every great racer is a great
manager in f1 manager 2022 you're the
boss which means it's up to you to pick
a great roster of drivers and staff to
help lead you to some w's keep your
finances in check monitor the
performance of your drivers plot how you
can steal staff from your rival teams
and more f1 manager 2022 is crossing the
finish line on august 25th for pc and
every console except switch
soul hackers 2 is the follow-up to demon
summoner soul hackers itself a sci-fi
spin-off in the shin megami tensei
franchise set in the same world as soul
hackers without continuing that tale you
play as ringo a character created by a
sentient artificial intelligence and
dispatch to stop some coming event from
ending the world with soul hackers 2
you're dealing with a group of
characters who are older rather than
those who are making their way through
high school but this is also a
supernatural sci-fi rpg so expect some
fantastical elements for instance there
are demons and you can summon them
according to atlas while the first soul
hackers had a pretty hardcore rpg ben
that might have turned off some players
the sequel is looking to be a little
more welcoming while also seemingly
borrowing a lot of what worked from
recent successes like persona 5 to
present a new story you can summon some
demons when soul hackers 2 comes to pc
and every console except switch on
august 25th
so which of these games are you most
interested in are there any that you
can't wait to play that didn't make this
list let us know in the comments and
stay tuned to gamespot for more
[Music]
you